Continental Tire coaches corner from
Sunday ranges snow and everything in
between
Continental Tire is engineered to tire
for what you do extraordinary
performance and reliability putting
confidence into driving for more
information and the location of a dealer
near you visit Continental Tire dot-com
Continental Tire for what you do Jeff
Van Gundy will join us in the
Continental Tire coaches corner coming
up here in a moment up take the poll
results if you can to clubbin okay it's
switch should draymond have been
suspended our and 52% say yes
Jeff Van Gundy will be on the call for
game six NBA Finals tonight along with
Mike Breen and Mark Jackson that'll be
at 9:00 Eastern on NBC actually Game
five coming up tonight we bring in Jeff
Van Gundy who Jeff let me start with a
poll question do you think draymond
Green should have been suspended no why
I don't I have a few things one I think
the point system in which they compile
these points is unfair to teams that go
further in the NBA Playoffs the point
systems to me should reset after every
series so that's number one number two
when you compare the Steven Adams hit to
this hit when you didn't suspend him for
that you've basically given license to
do things that were much less like green
did and and not expect repercussions and
so I really just I think there is with
players coaches organizations a growing
distrust for the discipline policies
that happen within the NBA and you know
Reggie Miller I think made a very valid
point he said if it was to - he doesn't
believe Green would be suspended and
unfortunately I think that's a common
belief that when they were down in
Oklahoma City
they didn't he didn't get suspended he
does get suspended when they have a
cushion of 3-1 now so
I think you know the NBA has to look at
the inconsistencies in their discipline
policy okay do you agree with Reggie uh
yes I do i yeah without question but
then the next follow-up to that Jeff is
did they do it to extend the series no
giving better no no no no I'm listen
that one doesn't mean the other I just
think that too often there are too many
factors other than the actual fact that
play too big a part in whatever if it's
a technical foul given later if it's a
flagrant upgraded downgraded a technical
given after the fact or taken back I'm
just not a fan of all of this stuff I
think it's it's it's convoluted and I
think it opens people up for questioning
and but I don't believe it's because I
don't think they're trying to do it to
extend the series I mean that that's a
corruptness yes and and so I don't
believe that at all but I do believe
fact too many factors other than the
actual act and I don't like the point
system and I just think it's
inconsistent
why was LeBron given a technical I
believe for the act of stepping over or
or I would say if it wasn't for that
then I would say it was you know going
face to face with green after the fact I
wasn't under the impression you could
give technical fouls you know after the
game huh listen I I don't understand
everything that happens after the game I
don't know who makes the decisions how
the decisions are arrived at with all
the increased quote-unquote transparency
I think how the decisions are made is as
unclear as ever or why they're made
yeah for all the transparency there's
not a whole lot of transparency there's
only transparency in the final two
minutes of games here Jeff well I think
that's another completely different
thing and I think a lot of players and I
would agree things that happen calls
made are not made in the first 46
minutes have every bit as are every bit
as impactful as the things that happen
in the last two minutes I understand
what the Commissioner is trying to do
with that I'm not sure it's serving the
purpose that he had hoped for talking to
Jeff Van Gundy of the mothership he'll
be on the call tonight with Mike Breen
Mark Jackson that starts at 9:00 Eastern
on ABC the trash talking to LeBron James
the fact that draymond Green would get
in his face and say something to him and
then the reaction of the Warriors
calling out LeBron cry-baby
you know I guess he's too sensitive it's
really strange to see that with the
biggest name in the sport and that
they're calling him I just can't read
could you imagine if they did that to
bird or magic or Michael or Isiah or
like their Kobe they wouldn't do that to
any of those guys but why LeBron I'm not
sure you know I don't know really how
all these things now work I did I don't
know what was said if it went over the
line if it didn't go over the line I
think you know these guys for the most
part players it's just different now
that everybody's so friendly that maybe
they feel like this is a friend that is
saying this to them versus another
competitor so I really don't know I
think in that way in many ways the leak
continues to evolve I think that in that
manner is a big evolvement a big change
in that these guys they're not seen as
different teams but that we're all part
of this big fraternity and I think maybe
that's what causes some sensitivities
what's Golden State do now with draymond
Green now how does that change there
style milena well I think it obviously
with him at center for a large part of
the game it impacts you know what they
do now whether do they start it with
Donna in his place I would suspect they
would but they're gonna have to have
either mcadoo on the floor more to place
you know that smallish Center or stick
with a traditional Center or even go
with Harrison Barnes and more guards you
know so I'm interested to see how they
play their best players keeping their
centers off the floor but it'll be
interesting to see if they can do that
with green out and for how long they can
do that
I think another part of it Dan it you
know doesn't get a lot of press is with
green out there down to 11 I mean
they're down an active roster spot
tonight which makes it a very difficult
decision for Steve Kerr I think in how
he goes about constructing his roster
for tonight last game yet yet floored me
you got me with the promo for OJ Simpson
the documentary and then all of a sudden
you have a story about Pat Riley and Al
cowlings at a car wash and they I mean
you've been sitting on this one for a
while haven't you Jeff I really I didn't
think was a big deal but I listen coach
told us that like 20-some years ago and
when they were reading the promo when
Mike read the promo that's what popped
into my brain and summarized it well
it's it's what I said you know like
coach had a place still in LA we lost to
Houston in seven he went back out there
he had known I think I think he knew
cowlings peripherally they were at the
same carwash getting their cars detailed
cowlings waves him over and says that
one of the reasons they were going so
slow or the reason they were going so
slow is that Oh Jay wanted to hear the
last part
Game five before he pulled in and so
coach you know relayed that to I think
was in that summer maybe before we went
to summer league and you know obviously
that was one of those Wow stories that
you you hear and who knows if it's been
embellished you know or it was
embellished by you know al cowlings or
not I mean I don't know I was in the
press room that night and there were two
monitors in there
one was the car chase and one was the
game and after a while nobody's watching
the game in that press room that night
well you know it's interesting being as
an assistant with the Knicks in Madison
Square Garden there there was a buzz and
a murmur but you know one knew what was
going on on the bench but you knew it
wasn't normal
you also saw a lot of people going in
and out like it was like it wasn't the
arena was not full at parts of the game
and I guess they must have had it on out
in the you know back where they buy the
concession or that yeah yeah in the
concourse so yeah it was just it was a
surreal night you know and I can't
believe so much time has already gone by
but you had no idea but you knew
something was going on and here you know
Riley is the head coach is different
than an assistant did you find out
during the game at halftime or in I mean
when did you know what exactly was
transpiring here you know oh that's so
long and I'm so old I don't really
remember that I think it was probably
after the game when did it start did it
start in the second half or it already
started in the first half I don't
remember that I thought it was before
half-time before half-time
yes yeah well we were a pretty focused
group led by an extremely focused and
great coach and so I don't think there
was a lot of chitchat about a car chase
at at halftime or you know but after the
game I do remember you know going back
dad left it for you
to the next day and that's all anybody
was talking about have fun tonight Jeff
always great to catch up with you thanks
for getting up early for us you got it
take care
that's Jeff Van Gundy the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience